live
cool we're going to see if we can get a
few cool things done
today it's been hectic it's been
hectic but um we're at the point where
we've got these guys running around
doing stuff right
we've got all sorts of fun stuff and
really at this
point I think we just have to figure out
how to clean up the environment so it um
it plays nice with puffer lib and a few
other things and we'll be able to
train that's what we're going to start
on today
right let me take a look at how we left
this
thing so right now we have two different
versions of this this
environment there's a syon version and
there's a native C
version
[Music]
and pretty much all we have to figure
out is how to make the native C
version uh play nice with
puffer and we will be good to go
there easiest way to do that should be
to
just from here
does okay we get some failed to open
file stuff that's
fine we just have to change this up so
that we are
loading right we just have to change
this up a little
bit I'm trying to think
how we should go about doing
this this is definitely the thing to do
today though
okay
um I'll tell you what we're going to do
I know I just started this but this is
going to be a little bit of a a little
bit of heavier work today I think so I'm
going to go put the kettle on for a cup
of
coffee uh and then we're going to dive
into all the different stuff here and I
think that if I if I'm able to just
buckle down and do this today we should
be able to have something training end
to end on the C version of the Moa and
then the project will just solve itself
from there I'm going to be right back
give me one second
so let's do the easy parts of this first
and then we'll do the heavier uh port
portions that will require some actual
engineering thinking in a
is I don't even think I need to do any
of this
right we just comment this
client hi
Adam computer science major in my second
year feel like a grasp of some things
well but when it comes to
coding mechanics or difficult technical
stuff I freeze up and can't solve a lot
of issues without external help you're
over complicating things I almost
guarantee you you're over complicating
things
um so one of the things that I I see a
lot of new
programmers uh struggle with and I did a
lot as well for many years is like you
get taught all this like object oriented
like design and you get taught all these
like highle things that require you to
exercise like a lot of subjective
judgment about like how to lay things
out they don't tell you that there
there's another option which is to just
not do any of that
so I will point you to the code for this
project I want you to take a look at
like here I don't know if you've been
following any of this stuff but this is
what we
have right now this is like a fairly
substantial MOA it's ultra high
performance engineered for reinforcement
learning it runs at like a million steps
per second it's got a bunch of unique
characters it's like miniature version
of DOTA
right do
this
uh I want you to see how simple the code
is like yeah it's in pure SA but ignore
that just look at how simple it's laid
out and how simply it's
[Music]
designed let me find the code it's all
it's one file as
well MOA
H okay like read through
this let's see where I paste this yeah
so read through this and you'll see what
I mean
like you'll see what I mean by like over
complicating stuff this is
like you don't have to think about like
the right abstractions and the right way
to do the stuff because there just
aren't
any and aside from that aside from like
just not over complicating things and
making your life harder than it needs to
be uh you need to just build some stuff
of your own that's the main thing you
just need to get out there and build
some stuff side projects are mandatory
CS curriculum does not teach you how to
build stuff you need to be like doing
you know your own side projects and
things don't get too hung up with like
no fancy text stacks and stuff either
right this freaking over complicated
JavaScript framework like that you know
obnoxious desktop app framework you
don't need any of
I think my mic is picking up that
horrible noise um I'm hoping that that
will stop at some point soon we've got a
little bit of construction going on here
let me see if I can just change the
Noise Gate on
through yeah that's coming through
that's awful let me
noise suppression hold
on what do I put on here so that this
doesn't do
this noise
suppression Noise
it you guys can tell me if that fixes it
or if there's still background noise op
does make sense but but when I actually
sit down try to get everything working
recoding yes exactly that's the problem
with oop just
don't just stop like you're making your
life hard
right I would just generally like and
this is something I wish I'd caught on
to a lot earlier like it's not like O is
just bad or you know this way of doing
things is bad it's that the thing that's
bad is trying to have a framework rather
than trying to solve a problem um and
like what I generally suggest is like
try to solve the problem first and add
structure only when you're absolutely
sure that you need
it so the easiest way to do that is just
simple procedural code right you just
like write the thing from top to bottom
in the simplest way
possible let me see can I crank that
noise gate up cuz I know it's really
obnoxious all the stuff in the
background let me see if I can fix that
test
hammering
okay uh you guys can let me know if mic
sounds good
here I I'll have to talk a little bit
louder but uh I think it should filter
out the hammering at least when I'm not
talking
and you're also free to just stick
around and like see the way that I build
stuff generally right I am very very
slow to add structure to stuff
the other thing that I will say that's
controversial is
like you probably want to avoid like
heavily functional code as much as
heavily object or code all like
principle over practice
where is this
getting getting like messed up from
somewhere here
presumably I have
to I have to do something about
rendering here don't
I dip to bed understand a lot of what
you do but coming here and chatting
sounds like yeah I mean you should not
be scared of like doing new stuff for
sure
um if second year like you've already
done some stuff for brand new program I
tell them to not try to take on crazy
ambitious progress cuz projects cuz
they'll get discouraged but yeah it's
second year you should be able to do
like some medium scope
stuff get used to
that I will also tell you
like use GPT and stuff for learning uh I
will tell you to avoid using GPT to
think for you like the plague though use
it for docs you can use it to like try
to figure out understand why bugs are
happening and stuff but like we're just
like you know here write this function
that does this I say avoid that like the
play cuz you won't learn
anything you can see that I do use auto
complete but I use it for like single
line stuff I use it to save typing not
thinking
stepping on your voice a bit
thinking stepping on your voice a bit too much okay hold
too much okay hold
on yeah sorry about that folks
it's what can I say this is this is just
the week that I have all the maintenance
going on let me see if I can uh fix that
how's that let me know if it's still
clipping
me I'll try to just talk
louder so the thing I'm having to figure
out here is I have this environment in C
and I have a binding for python but it's
not properly fully configured yet and uh
I want to make this thing not I want to
not add a bunch of overhead essentially
in the process of doing this
binding me see what it says Happening
Here interesting for some reason this
like bols what about here
why does rayb get
initialized where does RB get
initialized mean I have all this saved
so I can literally just cut
out all of this stuff
right cuz this whole client has been ped
to see
it oh it's also just possible that the
The Binding is bad now right
right this is the tricky thing about
having to integrate uh lower level stuff
with
python and this obnoxious binding layer
right
and this init mobile function is
not init mobile function is probably not
what we
want what are we doing we're binding the
uh the Coba to the python Library so we
can actually train directly on the C
version of the code um that way we can
have one to one the same training
environment so this will replace the
scyon code that we were using before for
training um but we have to get a couple
things right and I'm realizing now that
the way that I did this is
not the issue here is probably
that it's kind of an interesting little
uh technical
thing the right here this is how you
create the environment in C and you can
see that I allocate a bunch of memory
here right uh but the thing is we don't
necessarily want to allocate a bunch of
memory
because in the python version these are
buffers that get passed in from
python
so
yeah trying to think how I would like to
make this
MOA and most of the code is going to be
the
same almost all the code really it's
just the initialization of
like if I just pass in the buffers as
args and I just set them to like null or
whatever right
though guess it's going to be like
reward star
rewards
um
star rewards Norm
rewards what else gets allocated
the game
map that's kind of okay
here that's kind of okay as well isn't
it I think the AI paths here need to get
set the heck is the AI path buffer
[Music]
for oh right yeah that's rough
so this is what I did to make it run on
web we're going to need like two
versions of this init code
paths if it's unsigned charar or
whatever
there's just so much stuff that we
allocate
here I almost want to just like do this
right the first
time
yeah this is
tricky uh
environment I thought I did this with
the snake
environment how did I do
it okay so I made an anip function and I
made an allocate function right
better so the only thing that's slightly
annoying is
uh the amount of stuff in here but we'll
show you how we're going to do
this just
copy we're going to copy most of this
function I think this is all the
allocations
version which also returns you the Moa
like
this um but now this version
I'm understanding more the steps to Port
game
yeah yeah that's the idea here so the
key portion here right is that when I
Dev this I want to be able to run it as
a c stand alone which means that you're
running one of these environments at a
time and it's allocating all its own
memory but when you bind from python
what's very nice is to be able to
actually allocate the memory in Python
and then pass it to uh to your C code
because then you can do stuff like give
it shared buffers shared memory buffers
so your simulation is writing
observations directly into shared memory
you can do all sorts of cool stuff and
the only thing that you have to do for
that is you just have to have a version
of your make function that says here use
this memory as your buffers instead of
allocating it yourself so the allocate
version is what's going to be called
from C uh and that's what's going to be
you know doing all these calex the Alex
uh and then there's an init function
where if we're calling from python we'll
just call the init and we'll pass all
the buffers that we've allocated from
Python and what I was sort of hesitating
there over for a little bit was just
trying to figure out you know nice ways
of doing all that of course the one
thing that's really gross is that you do
end up with these giant function
signatures but um I haven't found a good
way around that
like it's kind of dumb to make a struct
MOA args just to get around function
signatures
right and speaking of porting stuff
here's a little bit of incentive for
people who are thinking about um adding
uh like making games and like porting
stuff for Puffer
this exists now we actually have a
showcase site where we're going to be
adding a whole bunch of M's including
ones that have been contributed by
people we're going to have all these
things playable online now now you can
just click around and like yeah here I'm
just playing the Moa now
right or now I'm playing snake right
really
easy probably just put one of these in
the background so people will have some
reference for what I'm doing
[Music]
here here you know what we'll like we'll
kind of like thumbnail bait just a
little
bit we'll go like this and then I'll
like I'll put us up here and then I'll
go like this behind my camera
think I use this original grid thing do
I I don't think I need it
either
right yeah no I don't need this
that's actually an efficiency
optimization I've made is no longer
needing to copy the whole map every time
you reset the
end so these are allocated
now what about the
map I don't need to allocate the map
itself here do
net this can go inside
of uh this can go inside of a
net get rid of
this m
withd right
well yeah we'll just do like that
don't need
this don't need
this oh wait no we do need this
right yeah we need all this
stuff actually hold on do we need this
pit stuff
here yeah we do what am I talking
about yeah cuz if we're not okay yeah we
do need
this e
we need
this now we shouldn't need these
because need
this zero outs scanned
targets they should go
the observation map to get initialized
here all this stuff is
RNG 10
kilobytes do I care about 10
kilobytes no I
don't I don't need to pre-allocate this
here
right okay so this is all of the
stuff uh that we want to
have only be allocated if we're going to
call the C version of the environment so
all these things are going to get passed
in from python if we're making the
environment from python all these memory
buffers but if we calling from C we need
to make them
ourselves now what we do is we call init
here this actually just
be W star rewards like this
now we just go from top to bottom right
so this is
rewards some
rewards HDs AI path pass
how big is
that and a
now extra action entities perfect so now
we get to the actual signature
is all this additional
stuff weit
MOA return
it there you
go there's your
allocation and then all we do is we
modify to modify the signature up
top we do end up with a couple chunky
signatures but that's basically the only
price of doing this
which is a very I think that's a very
reasonable uh a very reasonable price
right see whether this got all the types
right or not or whether I get burned for
accepting the
autogen probably I do
but
now the cool thing is going to be that
we no longer have to
do the alic is just
rewards
WS
it's to make sure that we're actually
copying the right stuff so the norm
rewards pids then AI
this we don't need these reset things
these uh these Setters here
no longer care about these right you
already have
these leave these
L we still
zero now this is observations
map very
simple RNG still gets allocated
yeah so just like that we now should
have two different
functions now of course we uh the one
slightly obnoxious thing right when you
do it this way you have to do free
MOA and then you have to do preallocated
oh
right
really all this stuff goes into free
allocated see what's not actually
allocated
so allocated
you have to just cut these things
out
map need two different freze
unfortunately one for if you construct
from C and then one from you construct
from python because if you construct
from python you're not going to free
python buffers from
do nice trick so we're doing uh we're
doing this for the python code but I'm
going to build it from C because I have
better faster compilation and better
debugging
here or C I can get the initial errors
out from here
I don't know what this first one
is why does it not like
hi Joseph guy from Discord having issues
with puffer you're working on MOBA oh
that's fine no no no you're you're
allowed to ask random stuff on uh on
stream that's kind of the point right is
that it doubles as
support uh were you asking about were
you the one asking about um
DMC by any chance
part of the point of streaming in the
first place is to help all the puffer
I am amazed that this actually appears
to work on the first
try we leaked a lot of memory though
didn't we
because this needs to be free Al
MOA perfect these memory leaks are uh
internal system stuff this is the
normal so we're good now we can work on
this binding me go get that guy back I
think he just like open stream type that
and close stream
oh no here he's here
cool um I think YouTube ate one of your
messages
here let me uh let me you can type stuff
in the Discord it won't censor you and
I'll respond live that's usually the
easiest if you want lower latency as
well it's jars 5341 on Twitch twitch
streams with lower delay um if that's
easier either way I'll help
rows well I'll I'll reply live here
right because I can give you a better
response than just via typing because I
can try stuff out live for you but like
if you just type there won't be a delay
and you won't get censored by the
YouTube chat but yeah leave stream open
I'll put this
uh okay here I
see H okay so you're trying the SP sp3
okay but you weren't just trying sp sp3
Let me see
well that's not good now is
it looks like I made uh some bug here
hold
on was this what you got or did you get
a different error
different error okay let me get to this
to see if we well this is training now
are you on the master Branch or
Dev put this on the side are you on a
master or
Dev other questions yeah I'll answer
I'll answer everything you got here this
is the point of me doing this stuff
live master I think okay
uh let me think how I do
this let me just make sure I commit
stuff I'm going to just open I'm going
to make a different a different clone of
popper so I don't have to mess with
Branch stuff hold on
main should be stable so if you're
having errors on Main that don't involve
a Dev feature then I will fix them right
if the error is like yeah it's just the
feature is not there yet then I don't
fix that on Main but uh if like
something is something standard doesn't
work on Main it
core if it
works
multicore okay so training does seem to
work did you try uh the clean RL one or
do you really want to use the SP sp3 one
cuz I'll help you if you want to use the
SP sp3 back end but I am warning you
that like uh typically our vanilla demos
like our demos are dramatically faster
than uh stable Bas L 3 I'll help you
with it I'll help you get SP sp3 working
though if you
prefer I mean we say that we have the
integration so
CLE
works3 used to it if you recommend yeah
I highly highly recommend um so for
context here puffer is incredibly easy
to use with vanilla clean RL if you just
want like our environments and our
vectorization it's out of the box um
it'll work if you want even faster with
more logging and like hyperparameter
tuning and stuff that's what our demo
file is for cuz our demo file is built
on top of clean RL and it has a whole
bunch of additional optimizations and
stuff um so you're free to use either of
those I have a lot of these things
they're tuned so like the demo works out
of the box with that at least with like
our default back end right now I can
looking at that error that you see that
I see right there I can tell you that
the uh the issue is
that you have to like for sp3 you would
have to make a custom policy uh and
you'd have to call like puffer li.
nativized tensor or whatever on the
observations because what puffer does is
when you have fancy observation spaces
it packs them into flat data buffers
because essentially like sp3 and other
Frameworks will screw up you give them
structured data so anything that is
structured data
we just give to you flat and then you
can unpack yourself um with that
function but you know with SP sp3 that
means that you have to have like the
custom forward function in order to do
that but the plus side is it means that
you can use know net hack you can use
nuro you can use all sorts of fancy
environments with just about
anything last hold on the Wasa model is
meant for learning or just inference the
Wasa model is for inference uh it loads
trained networks from pytorch and then
it does inference in
PC and you can see that demoed online as
well it's on puffer Dogg right now
though we have to retrain our models
I'll get deep into clean R anyways my
other question is
following check out the C code by the
way it's really like it's like 100 lines
for all the common layers that you would
need and then there a couple hundred
lines convenience bindings but it's very
nice when I pulled the puffer lib I ran
just like you did
yeah oh yeah you had issues with
resuming
right restart the
train let me see about that I haven't
messed with resuming recently cuz
frankly puffer is so fast that like the
thing just trains instant
anyways is the domain one time
pay it's got a renewal thing but it was
cheap what do you mean is it one
like it was
cheap it was really funny cuz some
[ __ ] tried to sell me puffer doio
for 15 grand so then I went and I bought
puffer Ai and puffer GG for like a few
hundreds
bucks Trad yeah so Trad checkpoint that
is that is legitimate bug let me fix
that for you right now uh cuz I was just
told this the other day that apparently
we're not using this correctly
yeah you're right it's not actually
called anywhere cuz was like I I broke
this feature at some point nobody's
asked me about it until just now but
let's uh let's fix that for you
X
byd okay so it passes ar. X ID
here
then it'ss called in train I
this already got a xide degenerated
somewhere
I see so this thing just doesn't have a
good way of telling if you uh if you
want to resume at the moment I think was
the
this I think I have to like return
whether you're resuming from
none so basically I have the function to
resume it's just like when I redid the
config system um apparently I I messed
with the way things are done
there I'm in the right Branch right I
hope hold on let me make
sure yeah I am in the right brand okay
see if I go into
train see if we get
true and right there is where we're
going to use this
checkpoint
if
mars.
no checkpoint I found found assuming no
experiment
okay now what we'll do is we'll just do
track run and experiment for a minute
and then I'll see if I can load from it
for what it's worth clean RL like
Vanilla Clean RL does not have
checkpointing by default we had to add
this you can see though that this is
currently running at 10K steps per
second on my like really old
desktop um it should be much faster than
that in fact if you tune like batch
sizes and
stuff I remember we can run the
environment itself at like
200k good
desktop I mean but regardless you know
two minutes for your million step
experiment funny enough is this is mini
grid right really simple and our MOBA
this training would take like less than
two
seconds I think our batch size is bigger
than a
million you can see the task is being
solved there episode return
actually if an academic lab really wants
it I will probably just end up redoing
minig grid uh in puffer relatively soon
you guys can have like a ultra high
performance version of minig grid that
sound
good would people like care about that
cuz if people actually use it and like
will care about it I will do that it'll
only take me a few days at most
I already have like a grid engine all I
need to do is add like the keys and
doors and stuff and maybe some graphics
no attribute compiled any grid changes
like scenarios randomly or they they're
predefined
scenarios we could do it so that they
change randomly I mean we can pretty
much do anything we want at this point
in the environment Sim Space like with
the stuff I've built now we've gone so
far beyond the typical like toy Ms that
are used in RL that it's essentially
trivial to implement any of the existing
little grid Ms at a thousand times
faster than they are
currently that's just
solved takes me a few days to write the
code for anything specific but that's
basically it
location oh there's no map device that's
weird
path there's something weird that I was
doing here let me see what it is
of model
half eight
I forget why I did it this way been a
while since I wrote
this wandb needs to seriously like fix
this thing where they spam the
okay I see I have I just have two
different um model path this is fine
this is correct
di to dict
like
it should be starting from a million
right what we'd
expect didn't need this Dash D track
either works I think well it didn't say
it said it it didn't say starting from a
million
right oh episode yeah but it should give
you the correct numbers we don't write
No Mediocre code around here right
it should
uh so the resume State here needs to get
applied
90 I don't know how often this how
frequently the default
saves but like let's say that I uh I
kill it
model we'll let it finish training cuz
then it'll definitely save the model but
as you say it's it's definitely loading
the policy it's just I want to make sure
that you have your correct numeric
stats want to make sure that we have you
set up before I go back to the MOBA
code and then if you have any more
issues with this please do report them
like this is a two-way street right I'm
happy to help with stuff but also I need
the user reports in order to know what
to fix like cuz that's the easiest way
for me to improv puffer right if people
tell me hey this doesn't work then
that's a lot easier than me just like
looking around blindly for things that
don't
work Dev moves very fast that means I
occasionally break things like
this CU this was a working feature
before one last thing yeah no worries
why is it not
saving more
stuff the trainer State should have
gotten updated
go ahead and ask though I'll start
thinking about it while I fix this
update one pop for Crea python file
creating blocks of code
okay I will I will check on that in a
second because that should definitely
work well unless there's like something
missing at the top but I will check on
that in a second let me figure out why
this stage isn't getting updated for you
first
save this should go here
right yeah it should save even when
you're not doing um one
work yeah that looks like I might have
messed with a rapper since I wrote these
these tutorials are so obnoxious to like
because they get stuff gets outdated and
stuff and I only know that they're like
outdated when people say Hey you know
automated test would fix this but then I
have to maintain automated tests
right and at this scale it's way easier
to just fix things like this for people
okay now if I run this again
the intended thing is it actually should
refuse to
train still not saving
really why is it still not
to I see why why this was here
right because it's supposed to
be it's supposed to be like
this but it's not actually giving me
this checkpoint message
trying to know where to start and it
kind of scared me yeah no it's this
should this should be much easier and
this is why I provide support right
because like I'm one person and uh I'm
usually quite busy developing all sorts
of new stuff right occasionally I will
like make little tweaks to things uh and
I'll not realize that I've broken like
some demo
somewhere but I think that generally
like if you start playing around with
puffer and this you know the other users
can attest to this you'll find that like
things are things generally are much
easier to have working and like when
things do break it is way easier to fix
stuff than in any other Library cuz I
don't have like giant Stacks and stacks
and stacks of like abstracted blackbox
code it's very very simple the
implementation of
stuff like you can actually read the
entire Puffer for Liv stack end to end
in a couple of hours and have a good
understanding of exactly how puffer is
doing everything which is not you can't
say that for any other Library other
than like clean RL which is well clean
RL doesn't do the lower level infra
right it just does the uh the train Loop
but like you can go through the whole
lower level infra Huffer in like a
couple of hours it's only a couple
thousand lines of code
I can get rid of this
check I don't think it's needed
charm that looks to me like I messed
with one of the rappers and broke
something most
likely we'll
see make sure that this works for you
first I need puffer Li stack visualized
in my mind well I have a white paper I
have the stuff on the website I have a
26 minute video going through the entire
RL stack and I have a hour and a half
video of me reading the archive paper
and giving all my thoughts on it I have
content out there for you
you I'm glad to see people actually like
getting engaged with uh know engaging
with the library and using stuff and
like no it's actually it's worth making
the content right if people actually use
it uh watch it and learn from
it let me know if there's other stuff
that would be useful to have that's like
you know decently able to
make just need to put the hours
in yeah it's probably like a good four
hours or so to like understand
everything but that's more than you even
need to start using it right that's like
4 hours to understand the entire
architecture of a library and also like
my plans on exactly what I'm doing with
the whole future of RL should be pretty
good okay so this is actually the
correct
uh this is the intended Behavior here
because it just should it should refuse
to train because it's done with the
training steps so if I just open real
quick config
yaml where is it config
yaml and I just increase this to
2 you can see now it'll keep training
right I fixed it for you
this really liked the section that on
Academia finishing PhD and can't talk
about this yeah I I know your
pain I went through there was much
suffering and none of it was my
advisor's fault my advisor was great but
like you want to you if you want to have
a fun time I I should show the uh I
should post the puffer lib paper reviews
like this is like a thousand star
insanely fast growing project with
full-time support and I got one of the
reviewers said that it would be damaging
to The credibility of nurs as a venue to
publish puffer lip how's that is a thank
you for doing uh know free full-time
open source work for the community
right [ __ ]
is going to be real damaging to the uh
credibility of nurs as a conference when
like puffer gets even bigger and this
review is on her own page it's like
well I am that petty I will put it on
the front page after uh the deadline for
first
stuff all right I'm going to push this
to main uh but you're going to have to
make me a deal okay I'm going to put
this I'm going to push this to main I
have not tested all the M's and stuff so
if you get any weird bugs with loading
or you get weird training bugs that mean
I probably broke something else really
important by pushing this to main for
you you have to tell me that's the deal
okay can we agree to
that I'll push this to main right now if
you're
agree okay got a
deal there you go there's your fix
welcome I've been looking for you you
know
I got uh some incentive for you to do
some environment
work puffer
Dogg your environment
here click
Play Click play loads
instantly runs neural nuts and browser
now capable of running Comet lstm
policies in browser too
this let me just make sure that that
wasn't a problem hold on I'll be back in
one minute
all
[Music]
right hey
folks trying to understand paper right
now so I'll get to anything that's
broken perfect and I can also remove
this noise filter now and talk
normally because the maintenance for the
day is done
if those are the questions for now then
I I'll get back to the MOBA stuff for
the time
being ping me on the YouTube chat or
whatever if I missed up but I'll try to
put this window up
okay let me remember what the heck we
were doing here right we were fixing the
python
bindings
so it's going to have to rebuild all the
scon stuff uh what we were doing now is
we were taking the C implementation
of the Moa environment and where we were
adding a code Pathway to bind it to the
python uh the python hooks for puffer so
that we can train directly on the C
version of the environment and then once
we retrain
correctly we will
um well we will be able to take
the the new policies and put them
directly onto the C version of the MOBA
and then it'll be trained and evaluated
in the same version of the environment
so it won't get stuck on walls and do
weird things like it's happening
now I have a quick question yeah no
worries uh okay I did not miss a Discord
thing
sure speaking of which if you're in a
lab that does a bunch of RL like we do
provide extend support for free to
academic Labs so that's a
thing I understand that the syon M are
much faster and it's easier to build one
with all that you've done as you
mentioned with rebuilding minig grid
y I assume the question is coming
next I plan to use puffer with an
environment using Unreal or RL in games
sure you can do that
gymnasium environment using puffers
gymnasium rapper yep that's
fine do you recommend something
else uh I mean there really
isn't there really aren't great tools uh
outside of that uh as far as I'm aware
not open sourced at least so yeah if the
easiest way is going to be to just have
something that exports uh state right if
you can get the game to if you can run
the game headless and get it to export
local state into like a reasonable
observation space right and then just
like ideally for train time if you can
just like cut down on any portions of
the game computation that are really
slow but uh are completely irrelevant to
training right you know maybe you have
just like some extra stuff for visuals
or whatever some pre-computation or like
some some uh non pre visual stuff like
anything you can cut down to make the
environment really fast is going to be
helpful to you but yeah you can just use
puffer gymnasium wrapper for uh for sure
like we have this Advanced API that I
use for uh the sea environments but
that's only relevant when your
environment gets to be really really
fast if you're not running it at like
you know well into the tens of thousands
of steps per second you can just use the
gymnasium wrapper and there's going to
be zero noticeable overhead
that's what it is there for right that
is what it is there
check okay so yeah this is still
academic work you're
good can continue discovery of puffer
tomorrow sure thanks for dropping
by seg
fault right let's see why this thing
segals probably wrong dimensions of
oh wow we got a lot of YouTube folks
welcome everyone
why is this thing seg fating doesn't seg
fault when we run it in pure
C well this function is totally
wrong oh that's so gross it just segals
if you have the function with the wrong
definition I guess
instead of giving you a reasonable error
message that's
disgusting no the C is fine the python
is fine it's the bindings when you go
between the two of them that's really
obnoxious every time
every
time but I think all I have to do is
grab this function signature which we've
tested in
right so now we have our uh our full
signature and then
we have to make sure that we're matching
this as
all though really this should not
seg maybe just seg fed because I didn't
Define the uh the Prototype correctly
I see the way that these are being
assigned is not good
either now that I'm looking at this
here yeah I think that we need to like
do this like one
end so that's actually much nicer like
yeah the uh the signatures are gross but
you can clearly see this is just like
passing a bunch of data to the
underlying in
net that should not have compiled that
quickly I can only assume it's um not
compiling the correct
stuff ah right
here for
and then it just needs AI path
buffer this was something that we
technically We'll add it just in case I
guess really shouldn't be necessary
though
but this is
good and then we have to to
okay
and can't include
R.H
right I remember this being a pain
do I have to just set this in LD Library
path
and that's really obnoxious that it
can't find
um the
RB
code I thought I'd messed with this
before and I'd found a good way around
this didn't I
when I was doing like the sea snake
stuff I do
not include D
here hang on maybe I can add it to
that
ooh that works
additional there might be an additional
include let's look at setup pi
no well it didn't re it didn't trigger a
rebuild right
see if this actually reg yeah this so
This
rebuilds do I
include but I don't see SL
lib
wait there should be a slash lib here
oh wait wait maybe this is the one that
needs the run time okay hold on I have
an
idea yeah so this this one needs LD
Library half equal
RB
right still
no could have sworn that would work
this and no chat
jity chat jippy
time I don't freaking know maybe this
will maybe this will have a summary of
docks
expected maybe you need this libraries
flag
would but sure why not we'll uh we'll
try
it each element in libraries must be a
twole what
huh it just said like yeah this aor
shouldn't be there
okay so they're just like there a bunch
of annoying Flags apparently
here each element of Library should be a
twole okay set up. P do
wow look at this this sample project
doesn't include all of the
stuff that you would actually need
oh I guess it's
uh no I have it
correct what the hell is this this is
like not the same as the
docks I mean this extra compile zard
thing doesn't exist right
Library
dur unknown distribution
option this is an option in
not do I really need to use this
extensions thing
everything gets dice here if I have to
um use the like the official like the
extension thing because it starts moving
your build files to dumb places
where's the docks for this
function why are there no docks
for so this is what we want
here I guess we have to do it this way
but it's very obnoxious because I'll
show you what happens
but literally like why don't they have
docks for this stuff like why is it so
hard to find the
docks for
okay here it
is
name not a file name but a python dotted
name okay
and then it says that we don't
need says we can't use this right it's
o error opening
file message file or directory but we
actually got
I guess these are like these paths are
done properly Maybe
I mean there are only so many places
that can go wrong
right we can just go like
this it would be really nice actually if
we could compile hold on instead of
doing this Jank stuff here
right I have one
it looks like we can do
it extra compile arcs
does this actually tell us now where SE
bolts
why is this taking so
long oh jeez cuz it's going to run the
address sanitizer
on it's going to run the address
sanitizer on the scon file right
want oh it did
build I think it did
build so let's let's see if it at least
does something for us now
let's see so this is they have extra
link
ARS well maybe they have extra link CS
let's see if this is
real and let's see if it's actually
going to take forever to compile
still because that's really
obnoxious I mean what's the alternative
to this though
right it's obnoxious how much code syon
shared
leisan I think we might not need this
one I think they said that you just
need F share to dress
maybe these compile times are just God
awful
though I mean at least I do all the
debugging for the most part in C
at least maybe this will actually give
me
something as soon as we fix this
compilation stuff I'm sure that the um
the actual like python binding is going
to be very very
simple for
not this where did the where did the
other one
go this is compiled
time for
it
yeah oh I have to do
export
oh that does
something hold on that actually did
something
oh the M the leaks are in the freaking
alligator itself what the heck
yeah no this is trying to run it on the
entire program let's not do
this let's just not do
this unfortunately this is like too slow
and too clunky to deal with doing it
this way
build and we'll do some
prints sadly that's going to be the
easiest way of doing it with um how
obnoxious the uh buffer bindings or the
the python bindings are
we'll just go to reset here and we'll
just add some print outs
okay perfect
so we get a resetting
towers and then it fails in res setting
Towers interesting
right do we pass these in the uh in this
order
though maybe we don't pass the buffers
in the right order
grid AI paths AI path
buffer pids
entities entity
data
OBS
map
extra or summer of wordss
Norm
actions that looks good to me
prints essentially what I think is
happening here is uh one of the
variables is not the size that I think
it
and then grid here is not good
right the grid is not good yes this is
what
address power
one
F oh yeah that's fine so this is
correct and
then the issue looks like it's with the
map
grid so why would there be an issue with
the map
grid let us see
right I'm going to paste the hard I'm
going to hard code the path for now just
to see
to
confirm and
uh actually you know what the easiest
way to do
this is to
just
if is there an exit there's no exit like
this and see is
there turn
one right
program is there an exit thing oh there
is an
build the load game
map ah and we actually have error
opening
it's 16,000
characters how much is
that that's a lot right yeah that would
be2 200 lines I don't want to just paste
that into the
file but like do don't
I imagine that I just pasted all that
data into the
file and then I never have to worry
about this path
issue I think what we'll do is for now
we'll just put the absolute path or
whatever but the thing is like I know
it's going to mess up
I know this is going to mess stuff
up wait you can just Tash include it
right
this is a
thing look at that that's freaking
hilarious yeah look at
that that's so
G that's really so
funny let's see do you think this
actually
works that's like kind of hilarious if
you think about it
this I mean on a scale of stupid to very
stupid I think that this is only like
somewhat
[Applause]
stupid and in fact what we can do what
we'll probably do is we'll take all
these constants that are at the top and
we'll like figure out how to get them
into one file eventually for
this is I just I just have to specify
the extra source file
game
map that age like this
oh that just
works I don't need to do
anything look at
that works
now
oops now we can get rid of all these
garbage prints
[Applause]
right it's kind of funny just to include
the uh the constants or whatever
HP do I need to call
this hold
on yeah so I do need to call this I
believe all I have to do this is easy
though this is what syon is
for this is very very
easy all I have to do is add the
signature of the exposed method
this and then I should be able to use
this method from
syon uh do I have to I think I have to
Define it here as well technically
technically
right maybe not I might just be able to
do
this let me
see I might have to add like a
little yeah I might have to add a little
binding here so because it's it's
uh yeah the reason I have to do this is
just because it's the object oriented
API which frankly there's Absolut no
reason to need it's just that like
python
let's see what happens if I have it to
set till one end instead of having 200
freaking
environments probably that's like
driving it
nuts there we go
puffer mode but has no attribute render
mode okay
render so I have to add the client here
then don't
client map
renderer game
renderer just do like this
we will
need render
free y this
one game render
and now all I have to do is we
add uh game
renderer well to this environment
really we just
add be def game renderer renderer right
and then on a knit here
we do self.
render none or null I should
say and then when we do
render reset step def render don't need
the sub
scale we do if render is null then we
init it
render render game S.M
frame mildly awkward but let's see if
this gets us
something okay cannot convert return
self. renderer well we don't need
need literally I only need the uh I only
need the Prototype don't
I hold on I think it's the case that if
you just I think you can just literally
do it like
this because the thing is like I don't
need to know it doesn't need to know
what that renderer
has right cuz I'm not actually like
making a game renderer in
yeah oh Rend mode perfect I saw it it it
popped up on my other screen hold
interesting oh but this is out of bound
stuff
okay so apparently the obser ations have
some weird data in
them so we'll have to fix that you know
we have a couple little bugs uh to fix
delt so here's what I'm going to do I'm
going to use the restro real quick I'm
going to take a few minutes here I got
to make myself a shake and do a couple
of things I'll be right back and then uh
we'll have like a good solid 3 hours in
which to try to get this thing to work
and uh we'll see how fast it is as well
I'm curious to see if it's fast already
or if I'm going to have to do similar
optimiz ations as I did before so I'll
be right
so why is there garbage data in
observations why is the garbage
data let's see
so let me also double check this slack
thing
whoops let me just check this real
quick
right GPU Drive folks were like ah it's
you know three years on one sim as well
seven on neural MMO
right yeah I mean all we got to do here
is um see if it sets the data at any
point to something stupid
right which
like oh which is right here right uh
this can't be negative
one do we zero this
somewhere yeah we zero this at the top
so all I got to do is move this
right cuz you don't want the negative
one that'll just be zero
right and
the
player empty
right
oops also is this even putting the right
thing into the
OBS it isn't right yeah it's got to be
map grid of address this was correct to
begin
with but
oh wait
Adder yeah yeah yeah
because this this should be this way I
believe I'm pretty
sure well no wait
when it should have been fine to begin
with right
maybe we just do
this it is rendering on the side screen
though it's just it's not rendering for
long enough for me to show you all yet
okay so
here we get Cuda
assert and we didn't trigger the
environment uh we didn't trigger the
environment print which is weird
right
so I don't know let's just go look at
the data Maybe
TCH and
then one
hot if CNN
here oh there's a bunch of garbage in
here
look at
uh presumably these are player IDs or
something right
dire so I don't see any
way I don't see any way that they should
be able to
be garbage
sense so we get zero and
one and then yeah on the reset we're not
going to see Towers or creeps or
anything like
this uh we get
six I don't know why seven isn't
here eight
this this is reasonable right you can
actually see kind of right that this is
the centered
agent and here are some other
agents it's got It's carry here it sees
its teammates
right one
uh this one se's
garbage two
again this one is now this is correct
right well hang
on is this correct I don't see a
centered agent on
weird is there like a sign issue or
something dumb
unsign Char star observations
map unsign Char star observations map
I mean could it be in the wrong
order is this like a wrong order thing
maybe
so it's also very weird to me that
like you don't ever see the data being
written
oh wait hold
on
viz
oh now this is good isn't
it 11 by 11
by4 observations map
this could also be a memory
thing which we'd be able to check for in
purec
I'm trying to think like what this would
even
second I have an
idea I have an
idea if I do
this is it still broken
Bren cuz this is the only other place
I'm setting map data
yeah still getting all this
garbage wait did I
recompile I don't think I recompiled did
I yeah I did
[Music]
okay so that doesn't
anything
right for
data but there's a bunch of garbage in
here and I'm not even setting it right
oh wait hold
on
um if this is what I think it is I'm
going to be really very quite irritable
I'm going to be very very
irritable and I think we're all going to
learn
something we're going all learn
something very
silly I could be wrong if I'm wrong here
though I have no idea what the hell it
would be
yep that fixes
her
so God how do I even explain what this
mess is
so maybe I should just go to the file
and show you
okay
so where the hell's the
data okay so right here was the
problem I didn't even know that this was
remotely possible for what it's worth
so what appears to be happening here
right is
that I split this data along the last
axis
here so basically I split the data along
columns and then I pass these pointers
separately into the
environment uh the issue with doing that
though is that those are actually not
contiguous chunks of memory
so when you give it the pointer to the
map there's like some data in the first
row but then it's not contiguous and
then you right into the next data so by
setting the extra data I was overflowing
into the map
data which is very
silly very
silly and actually now that I'm thinking
about it very very difficult to avoid
like I'm going to have to make
this just be flat buffer data right
that's
irritating all right I know how to do it
it's going to be obnoxious though so I'm
going to take a quick
second check a couple things finish the
shake and then we'll get into
that really cool to see the amount of
support on this
see so what we're essentially we're
going to have to do is we're going to
have to ocate just one observation
tensor and we're not going to be allowed
to slice it we're going to just have to
pass that big block of contiguous memory
into C and then we're going to have to
manage it
ourselves obnoxious veryy but um I mean
the cool thing with
this this means that our
simulation this when we run this
distributed the C code it's going to
literally from C it's going to be
writing data observation data directly
into big shared memory buffers so like
you instantly have access to data from
all the different simulators on the main
process which is very very
cool it's also something that
is completely
impossible um if a simulator has not
been designed with that in mind at least
to some extent like you need to have the
output buffer be an argument to the
program
essentially
okay 5:00 p.m. I've got two and a half
hours to get this
done this and several other things
and this is what we're going to
go we have to change the signature as
well
this is the one downside of having
um you know these bindings look like
this you do get these at least I mean I
can't even really say that this is like
a downside of The Binding as much as
just like this is a very fancy
environment that has a lot of different
types of fancy data in it probably by
the end of this we're going to discover
that some of these are redundant we'll
be able to pair it down at least a
little bit but but for now you know we
do our we do our little bit of
formatting here and
there there so we got rid of the
OBS now here this is just observations.
data no longer need
this and we are going to now be fully
responsible for managing this giant
obnoxious block of contiguous
memory uh which now that I'm thinking of
it is going to be even less fun than I
originally
anticipated oh
joy yeah that's going to be even less
fun than I originally
anticipated that's okay
it is actually going to look a little
simpler when we're done it's just going
to hurt my brain a little
bit it's
pids and now right here
I think what we how we can do this which
will be a little bit nicer
so now we get a 2d array with this nice
view and
then we can do OBS map
right is going to be equal
Pati what I'm doing here is I'm grabbing
the first uh the first bites of the
current row of the array and I'm going
to put them into this OBS map and then
OBS xra
here this one doesn't need to be
multi-dimensional because it's just it's
a a flat buffer like
this this is just and uh
obser vations
of 11 * 11 *
4 and I think that this will allow us to
do I mean we're going to have to figure
out this intax here but I'm pretty sure
that with this we can leave everything
else exactly the way it was and it'll
work uh of course in order to confirm
this now I I'm going to have to mess
with the Moa C
code which is a bit
obnoxious and also now we have to do
some data splitting [ __ ] I
think which will make our C forward pass
uh slightly
slower not really actually not really at
all I think it'll be about the same
speed
oh yeah look so we have this net OBS 2D
this is totally
fine here this is going to be
observations start
actions okay
I think literally all I have to do is
add 26 to
this we're going to get rid of all these
magic numbers at some point obviously
but I think in the meantime literally
all I have to do is add 26 to
B *
26 what the
this oh because it's n OBS one
which no longer exists so this is
observations we'll have to do a little
bit more
11 * 11 * 4 plus I I'm fairly confident
that's
correct not
positive but fairly
confident and actually in some ways this
simplifies the code it makes the
indexing slightly more
obnoxious makes the indexing slightly
more
obnoxious but that's okay
it does actually reduce some
code what the
heck invalid decimal L
what uh did I corrupt my build file
somehow
oh I'm
dumb
there
okay then we have to
go get some basic
bugs this is n of observations not
observations map
declared subscripted value is not an
array pointer or vector
this I have no idea whether this is
efficient we're going to I suspect this
function is going to need some perf
optimizing so probably we're going to
get stuck doing perf optimization
tomorrow for be decent chunk of
time but uh I mean there's no reason why
it should be slower in C than cython
obviously it should be a little bit
faster in fact
so we should be able to hit well over a
million steps per
second million agent steps per
second and see maybe
and we forgot that we have more
signatures to adjust I really don't like
the number of times you have to uh have
like the top level boiler plate but like
some of that is a little outside of my
control because like scon mandates a
little bit of it and like without scyon
we'd be having to write
um like the python
API which you clutter up your
C I don't know maybe I'll try but I
definitely wouldn't put it in the same
file it
mobile observations map so this is
observations yeah there's so many
different places where you have to do
this stuff kind of
disappointing allocate
MOA all right and then
gross * 4
plus6 like this is what it should be now
this is just observations
uh okay the policy actually work it
seems like they do the same thing as
before I mean they're not amazing but
they weren't amazing to begin with
right and he's still doing his
thing let's see if he goes and uses some
abilities
yeah look at
that
cool so this guy is
solid now let's see if we can get the
python version
working we did all of this so that the
python version would actually have the
correct memory addresses and the
observations so we would get correct
observation data
all I got to do is delete
uh a bunch of garbage
here really just these
ones let's you know let's leave them for
now cuz I might need them let's just
comment
them cuz I did just mess with the neural
net
folks now this is a little concerning to
me that it hasn't done stuff yet
uh oh wait there's a
window but it's not working
happening I swear this never works the
only thing that actually ever works is
this like Overkill
there where's the
process right here 88
right I don't know how that's even
possible
literally it's like freezing up my uh my
terminal
here I'm trying to think how that's even
possible
manager no I can't even see it
here I can see it here but it's just in
right python binding to uh C program is
unkillable
well kill dash9 does not actually
work let's I get the PID wrong or
something oh it says it's
gone but I still see it I see it in the
taskar
oh okay there it goes I guess it just
took a
second uh of course now I have to
immediately run it again
which is not
amazing but I mean what else am I
supposed to do except hope that was just
a
bound that a break point
there for when we eventually figure out
how to kill this
stuck how is there this thing like this
unreadable
window
right that shouldn't be a thing
what if I
se
it that
no literally unkillable
process kill all all
Ray yeah I've had to do a lot of kill
all Ray in my
time incredibly weird though this is not
even being
multiprocess it's just for whatever
reason like I have this python binding
to this C code and I don't know how but
it's like
unkillable it does eventually
stop failed to resize TTY
weird okay there we go so now I'm I have
a breakpoint set at least so we'll see
when this happens
really that doesn't make sense to me it
should not be able to happen
immediately I mean we've made some code
changes I
guess here we'll mess with the c version
that doesn't do this as soon as I fix
this one
it stops using memory immediately it
stops like using compute but it just
sticks around
lovely oh yeah my Linux subsystem is
locked up
completely so I guess we're going to sit
here waiting for it to decide to fix
itself otherwise I'm going to have to
reboot the whole
machine well I guess I could reboot WSL
as well couldn't I I'm going to give it
a second
first let me give it a second first to
see if it just decides to to figure
that doesn't look like
it's
stuck can it literally not shut down
WSL I've seen a lot of crazy things in
my time I haven't seen that
well folks I'm going to have to
oh there we
go
works just as I was about to say I had
to reboot the
machine so this time we're going to mess
around in the C version for a bit and
see if we can figure out what the heck
is happening before we do that
again but sometimes development be like
this
okay so we can see right
here this version is
fine right this version here is fine
so the underlying C code is
good uh hold
on there's a weird
free I wouldn't think that that would do
anything but we can go check it out
this doesn't need to be
freed
oops and there we go this is back to the
correct memory profile these are
internal meem leaks can't do anything
about
I mean I don't want to run the python
because we know what happens but like
you know what else do I do in this
situation
right why the heck does the python do
this I can make a standalone script I
guess to try to test it
it's just very odd to me like what the
heck would cause this
right there really shouldn't
be there shouldn't be anything capable
of causing
this I mean I can try to run it without
rendering
on if I think it's the
rendering but I don't know if I think it
is the rendering
like man I should at the very least be
able to uh to just instantiate this
thing
right I'm have to do everything fully
from scratch
okay okay let's see if this does
anything
right so it's
like
or see does this do anything
yeah so that
runs
step oh you do give it to actions like
this
right hold on there's this like weird
gross thing here
it well this should cause a seg fold it
shouldn't cause
this I guess it's undefined
Behavior still shouldn't be able to do
this
so we just do like this right
um that
back and then we
do 9 *
and it's Nots type float
32 we can just do like this right we do
step all
weird right we can do like this
instead that should maximize the chance
of us not getting get
controlled by uh whatever the hell this
bug
is missing all right we give it actions
here we not
get could not broadcast
pi and then you actually don't have to
give this any
ARS it has the
data very
nice that's
[Music]
MOA okay so what we can do is let's do
like you know for Iron Range of like
30 we'll see how this
works works very nicely right doesn't
crash doesn't do anything
Point Let's see about this now this is
where the things can get
stupid let me show you that we have we
have a frame right this is a
frame okay
if we don't put this break point what
point okay it like renders and then it
goes
right so we have something uh it's not
loading the shaders and stuff which is
why you can't see anything so uh we'll
have to fix the asset paths and
such but uh yeah I will be I'll be right
back and then we'll try to figure that
out we're making some decent progress
for
well we know why the uh the paths are
wrong here
get well duh that's get current working
directory for
not current working
directory I'm just trying to figure out
like what's the easiest way
to to load
files from the uh the directory that
this thing is
in
read
link the hell is
this is relative to the current working
directory is the annoying thing
this and why is this so obnoxiously
silly shell out to
Python and read standard wait
what what are you talking about that
guy I the issue at the moment is just
that I
have I mean it's really
dumb I was going to say that didn't seem
to make any
sense like the issue here is I have the
C right and I have the Assets in the
same folder but then when it gets
compiled by setup.py it gets compiled
from like the root directory of puffer
LI or whatever is really
obnoxious I mean yeah you can
technically do that but then this file
doesn't like this thing doesn't build
and unless you like [ __ ] with the
paths the easiest thing would just be to
have like the
uh well actually no the easiest thing
wouldn't be to have uh the absolute path
if you think about it right
because hold
on yeah no it's the absolute path that
works easiest thing is to get the
absolute path to the current directory
what's the
issue so I have a C file right it loads
some assets some pngs and stuff and it
works fine but then when you run this uh
when you compile this and run it from
python the working directory is
different because you're running from
like wherever the hell the python is um
so then it's not finding those folders
right it's not finding those assets so
like the easiest thing I could think to
do would be to have the
uh I mean it should be the absolute
path
right can you
pass file is an argument
CWD that shouldn't be a thing you should
just be able to get the path to the
current f while
very
silly I mean I have like there are
functions for this I just think that
they're too complicated for what they
yeah I don't know it's doing weird stuff
and what it
silly I'm trying to think what I would
want to do for this
I mean even if I pass the
path I guess I have a text format thing
that makes it slightly
easier can I hold
on let's say I do want to pass
the the path right
right let me see how obnoxious it
dependent I mean by OS dependent you
mean Windows versus literally anything
else
I mean I could just use
this and pass the path through
this it's very
obnoxious no I mean really should I want
you should be able to run the SE stand
alone from any directory so I don't want
to depend on this
[ __ ] we need to really just figure
this stupid thing out and see
silly those are just
so it can't be this [ __ ] stupid to
have to load a file right it can't
possibly be this stupid there's got to
be a way that doesn't make you look like
an imbecile
and come on running a file from a
different directory
current yeah so you do that and then you
[ __ ] over your
packages like you [ __ ] over all your
other python code
like GPU Drive does this and it makes it
uninstallable with
Pip I guess technically you're not going
to
run you're not going to run the program
from a different directory
right can't adust python or assist path
as
needed and
yeah does that even propagate to uh the
C
code I don't know if that even
propagates to the C code
quick are you running from subprocess or
multiprocessing I it might
disgusting plus Ultra can we do this
though
obnoxious do I really just I guess I
have to just pass the [ __ ] directory
to
see
right and then I have to conditionally
apply it if I'm
like CIS path
okay I just
add the
disgusting yeah this is just spamming
garbage don't bother checking chat GPT
it's always wrong
wrong man I didn't expect this to be the
thing to get stuck on right
it really doesn't feel good either to
like have to change the uh the C code
the C is nice and
be
huh
can we do like
this oh I know what happened
yeah this is not path it's like it's
basically you need like a [ __ ] Sim
link or something don't you
I mean
technically if we're going to be just
really stupid about things
right if we just want to be really
stupid
here can't we just
like work
for I can't freaking pay stuff from
this if we're going to be just really
dumb
this why I use path Li does that help
you when you're loading stuff in
don't have full docks or
stuff like it's ridiculous the chat
jippy has like better docks because
they're just not anywhere they're like
some obscure page on the internet
hell is what you're trying to do get the
ABS well what I'm trying to do is
I have assets that need to be loaded in
C and in C you know you specify the
relative path to them which is what you
would always do uh but because this
thing gets built by Python and it gets
imported and like called from separate
places it doesn't work so I'm trying to
make the C path actually work it's
driving me
nuts what the hell is this
right for
nuts you get stuck on the simplest
things right
function how is this still not loading
successfully
shaders how wait we're loading stuff
successfully now but it's not showing
up oh wait hold on am I just like
incredibly dumb wait hold on let me just
try something
something maybe this is something
completely
different no that did make a
difference so here it failed to open
everything
and then when I did this stuff here
map
Shader why is it loading the wrong
it
finally [ __ ] a
that is so
stupid that is just so stupid how long
that
took cool
take and
take take
compile then we'll actually get to clean
this stuff up a
bit all
so here's the
N oh it's random action so that's
fine yeah but you can see it's
wonder we'll have to do perf test later
but
um yeah that gives us the environment
rendering now we had some uh some
bug some odd weird reports of stuff I
think in the compute OBS functions
let's go see if we can actually run the
demo
okay well I don't know what was cursed
with
this but it seems like whatever we just
did fix some
we got to expose variables and stuff but
yeah that is kind of
well and
then total tow is taken
I think the only stats that you really
need is uh the only stats you really
need
here from the environment itself are
this right you just need these
like at
property
close this is not an allocated MOA this
is
just
MOA we also haven't defined it here so
we need to
Define
all right
so here's our
policy look at
that and we load the
policy they don't look particularly
oh these buttons do
work so our view buttons work we can
look at any of
them that's cool they just need to be
doing stuff
I call that a
success I call that a success for
sure we really need to train some new
policies on
this I think the Clusters still down
right it came back
up oh what Nathan posted new
M what is
cool that's was cool to see I have no
idea what that is
but so uh we should probably figure out
how fast this thing is
why can't I see the freaking syntax
error
stupid
there we go
I don't like that it loads RB even when
I don't render
okay so according to this this runs at
240,000 steps per sec uh
204,000 steps per second on my
desktop which I believe is quite a bit
slower than the um the scon version so
we'll have to figure out where I'm
dropping performance
there let me
think yeah I have to figure out where
we're dropping performance
uh oh also though technically is
this No it should be faster than that I
believe should be faster than
that so we'll have to profile and do
stuff on that but it's not
horrid it's not horrible
open oh yeah wait the cluster is
up so we should be able to do some stuff
let me make sure we can actually train
on this
how big is
this we
do 8 by 8 so600
shouldn't we might have to initialize
render at
um and we might have to do some stuff
here
it's funny I'm like very dissatisfied
with the bindings between Python and C
I'm very happy with the python and
puffer I'm very happy with the c and
Puffer not happy with the
interoperability of the
two like what is this
right I assume it's like making the
environments or something right
okay one
n let see what happens
64m takes too long to
initialize no reason that the M should
take any real amount of time to
initialize like this
I guess it's having to do
um well no it shouldn't have to do any
file IO
involved very awkward that it's like
it's still
not
32 we're going to have to look at the
initialization time
now and figure out what's happening
because this doesn't make any
sense hey
yes why
Linux yeah I mean that's got to be a
joke
right yeah got to be nuts doing stuff
not on Linux
well this is
weird it
initializes one two four or eight
environments fast and then it just hangs
on
I think what this would even
be you make more than 8 m it just
doesn't work
I mean I'm technically giving them the
same AI pathing
data but they're not writing to it it
shouldn't be locked or anything
process oh wait buff observations right
here yeah this is wrong isn't it
right so I don't know why that would
make it
that doesn't make it
fail
interesting so it gets 14 M's
in and then it
breaks on the reset
weird I'm trying to think if there's
anything where I could have like the
indices
wrong mm's no I
have I'm agents
I mean I would get like a bounds error
in Python if I gave it the wrong
index is this like memory somehow it
can't it shouldn't be able to be
I don't know why these processes get
like backgrounded either
where's the obnoxious one I swear this
is the only one that ever works and it's
too obnoxious to
remember see
works
100 is there a while loop somewhere that
can be
infinite oh I
know that's really awkward isn't
it I know what it
repeatedly so there's a rare condition
you can technically infinite Loop in the
environment if there's nowhere to spawn
and I was filling up all the spawn
positions because I was writing
everything all the different
environments onto the same
map I'm pretty
sure
no it says no where still looping
here I could have sworn that would have
been
n like they use like no
memory they're
great we are perfectly set up
here they really shouldn't consume much
memory nice to see that they actually
don't uh so now I should be able
to first of all
M right and then this is going to be 10
* m
time
faster okay there we go that's a lot
closer to the original performance
um typically the uh the puffer boxes are
like a good 2 and 1 half times faster
than this box so this is about close to
the original million steps per second
we'll have a couple little optimizations
to do you know I'm probably I missed a
couple things while doing the port but
uh yeah there we go
right that is fast that is like
incredibly fast that's like you know how
is the environment that fast right
let's order some food real quick on the
side and uh then I will keep working on
this until it gets
here that's what we'll do
today I want to check one thing on
Twitter
some
food uh what do I get here
config cuz now we know we can do some
crazy things
right see can we run the full config
already or are we going to O ourselves
we probably shouldn't right we just
confirmed that they're like they take no
memory the default config is like 200
per core
200 m is like .1 seconds to initialize
on each core
independently oh look at
that that is the startup time for
running a million steps as
well 130k local
so there are a couple things that we
want to do
all there's a lot of stuff to commit
isn't
there let's do this first so we don't
lose stuff
ELO there was something I messed up when
I did these ELO
CS believe
thing I want to check that uh I think
there was a PR that I got to merge one
second
now we'll just fix there's one thing I
wanted to fix which is that I wanted to
randomize the team that this is on right
now it's just like it puts your team on
radiant 100% of the
time I think that that is going to
be h
that might be a thing for tomorrow
though I think we just get this thing
running for
now here
the heck was puffer net.
PX I wasn't ciz
that is there a puffet px I guess there
is actually isn't there
1.6
megabytes that's so funny
I do this in the wrong one I totally
just did this in the wrong
one damn
hello you trained the strongest model
and loaded it into 10 bot in the demo
even the red team so here's the thing
um we've had better models one the last
experiment sweep had a couple janky
things that we need to fix and two
there's some minor differences between
uh the N before and after I ported it
and probably a couple unintentional
differences so it's technically being
put into an environment that's not
exactly matching the one it was trained
in and they're probably some weird bugs
so yeah the models in there at the
moment they're not very good at all uh
we will be upgrading them and I just now
like literally right now I got it to the
point where we can train uh ostensibly
at least we should be able to train
directly on the C version of the
environment so we're going to train some
models we're going to run some hyper
parameter sweeps and we're going to
refine our training pipeline a little
bit and then we'll get better and better
models but the cool thing is now that
this envis in C
um it's very very quick for us to Port
new models over to the seu which is
pretty cool whereas before it was like I
couldn't put them online or you know it
was completely
separate now if you want to do
um if you take the blue models by the
way so if you take the blue agents and
if you just get them unstuck here let me
show you something so first of all we've
we've got this new
site. for this and if I get the agents
unstuck right so here we'll follow this
one and you'll see that they get
stuck but like if I just switch to this
agent
here and now you can see I got this one
unstuck watch they actually do
reasonable things like they just don't
know that the terrain is where it
is so like you see it just dashed it
just dashed in and now it's going to use
its AOE tock clear these minions and
clear the
tower so like it's learned to do a
couple things like they actually do
learn to use their abilities and stuff
and I have charts from the hyper pram
sweeps that can show you that like
they're actually effectively learning to
use all their abilities and such but
like there are some bugs and some things
that are going to need to be fixed for
this
also the snake model the snake model on
the website is really stupid I dumbed
that one down because I didn't have
convnets and lstms implemented in C when
I made that so we're going to upgrade
the AI for the snake as well pretty
soon I got to figure out like a cleaner
way of doing this like you know python
like C to scon to python binding stuff
though because right now there's a lot
of just Jank overhead associated with
like getting the EnV to play nice with
puffer and also run a native c um like
the python stuff super simple and easy
the C stuff super simple and easy
getting those two things to work
together is a
pain that's the current state of
things and hey we're looking for people
to build more of these environments if
anybody if you know if you want to like
build some cool stuff learn some AI
learn well I don't know what your
experience is with RL but like if you
want to like learn some cool hyperf Sim
Dev uh we have people building like
building and contributing a few of these
at the moment in the Discord it's a good
time
this wait
what uh
builds okay here we go
so now we have it
training on the C version of the
environment at
400k 400k steps per
second should be about the same as what
it was
well very nice
so uh we're GNA
see cool this probably won't be an
amazing sweep but I figured we'd just
get something R running today
uh most likely it'll crash on some like
weird edge condition but at least
that'll help us find one bug and uh you
know maybe that'll help us find one bug
or
something so we'll
see very unlikely that I've just made
this port perfectly uh on the first
training
run but hey who knows maybe it's
good I think we should be fairly happy
overall with this
though I think we're going to call it
for tonight cuz my food's going to be
here in a bit I got a couple quick
little things to do around the house
uh and I'll be back
tomorrow and tomorrow I think we get to
do more experimental side stuff and we
also get to we'll also get to figure out
if we can clean stuff up uh and like I
really want to make it easy for people
to make and bind these
environments so I really want to clean
that up and make it very simple um like
this site needs to have like I want this
site to be the go-to place for RL
environments
you know like we have these couple I
want to add a few like Atari remakes
that are way faster I want to add some
grid environments I just want to add
tons of stuff here it's like hey all the
environments that you would ever want
for reinforcement learning research they
run at a million St million plus steps
per second per core uh they run on the
web if you want them to they're
incredibly easy to use and install
right this should just be the state of
research and we're very very close to
making that happen and I think once we
do that like the field is just going to
accelerate so so so quickly just based
off of that speed difference and that
usability
difference so anyways thanks for
dropping by and uh yeah I'll be back
tomorrow good night